my musical training was the key to my
discovery it was not an engineering
discovery or a mathematical discovery it
was altogether an ear discovery in
autumn of dis of 1967 while
experimenting with two oscillators one
producing a vibrato in the second so
basically it's infrasonic FM only I
didn't call it FM it was just vibrato as
I increase the vibrato depth and at sub
audio rates and I could track the
instantaneous frequency as long as the
rate was not too great I increase the
depth and the rate to the point where I
could no longer track the instantaneous
frequency and then realized I was
hearing just this complex tone I decided
to increase both of these values around
a carrier this average frequency 200
Hertz from maybe the vibrato depth 200
Hertz so that would be from 0 to 400
this was a linear system of course and
then increasing the rate well so one
tries even numbers like 200 I'll try
5500 and 200 and then I thought you know
what I'm hearing is a complex tone that
seems to have be made of harmonics
that's what my ear was telling me I put
an envelope on the amplitude of the
modulating wave and of course I knew
that with zero amplitude I just got a
sinusoid and of course then I heard this
dynamic spectrum and my ear grabbed that
and understood immediately what was
going
although I didn't know the process I
knew that I heard that what I was
producing was something like a filter
being swept over a complex wave the
obvious thing to them well let's see if
this transposes so I tried the same
thing at 400 Hertz maintaining the
ratios then at 100 Hertz and then
realized that there was something
important here
brass tones had not been successfully
simulated I thought well if I'd use a
trumpet envelope on in a similar way as
the modulation index that would meet the
criteria that jean-claude had respect in
his simulations using no 10 or 15
oscillators that I had produced these
pretty believable trumpet like brass
like tones and it transposed so put
things down in octave and slowed up the
attack portion and those were fig
brasses put it down and then never big
tuba like tones so I realized that sort
of made a breakthrough because this was
a category of tones that was very
difficult to produce so here I had these
two oscillators using the same envelope
just tape
changing the time constants a little bit
I had this whole family of brass lake
instruments and I knew then that that
there was some importance in this
discovery beyond my interest in using it
in composition